j'ouvre tout de suite le second débat de
ce sens public consacré à la fin de la
nuple Conseil national du Parti
socialiste a voté le moratoire proposé
par Olivier fort à plus de 54 % et
suspend donc sa participation que
décident les autres partenaire
écologiste et communistes comment faire
revivre une union de la gauche sans
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et ses fidèles
pourquoi les attaques terroristes du
Hamas ont servi de détonateur à cette
ultime crise avant d'en débattre le
récit d'une implosion avec Fabien rker
la nupè est-elle définitivement enterrée
par une résolution votée cette nuit le
PS suspend sa participation à l'Alliance
de gauche en cause les refus répétés de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon de qualifier le Hamas
de mouvement terroriste Jean-Luc
Mélenchon est devenu un obstacle à
l'Union nous dénonçons sa stratégie de
conflictualisation permanente qui
interdit tout élargissement le Parti
socialiste décide d'un moratoire sur sa
participation aux travaux de laanup si
les querelles sur le Proche Orient
emporté un nouveau coup à la nuupesse
celle-ci avait déjà du plomb dans l'aile
affaire catnince stratégie sur les
retraites ou réaction aux émeut de cet
été autant de sujets de discorde entre
LFI et ses partenaires pendant très
longtemps nous avons fait en sorte de
cheminer collectivement et d'essayer de
porter une parole spécifique à gauche il
s'avère que cette parole a été sans
cesse remise en question par les prises
de position à titre individuel la
plupart du temps de de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon officiellement la résolution
du PS ne fait que suspendre la
coopération des députés socialistes au
sein de l'anupes mais pour le sénateur
Patrick canner opposant de longues dates
à toute alliance avec LFI le texte voté
en bureau national ne va pas assez loin
pour moi il ne constitue pas un acte
suffisamment fort pour dire à LFI ça
suffit Monsieur Mélenchon ça suffit il
faut vraiment tout remettre à plat cette
nupesse aujourd'hui pour moi est une
impasse politique dimanche le Parti
communiste avait déjà fait un pas vers
la sortie en votant sa propre résolution
qui actait l'impasse de la nupesse mais
sans pour autant claquer la porte chez
les écologistes on appelle à un nouveau
type d'union pour que on évite de
rentrer dans un schéma où les gauches
seraient irréconciliable il faut qu'on
arrive à trouver un cadre collectif de
travail pour la gauche che les
écologistes pour pouvoir travailler une
candidature unique en 2027 mais où tout
le monde se respecte mardi la chef de
fil des députés écologistes appelait à
réunir une assemblée des 151 députés
nupes pour jeter de nouvelles bases à
l'union de la gauche une union au sein
de laquelle Jean-Luc Mélenchon fait plus
que jamais figure
d'épouvantaille la fin de l'annupèe
l'avenir de la gauche au programme de
notre débat avec Lucile schmi bonsoir
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
vice-présidente du cercle de réflexion
la fabrique écologique et auteur de ce
livre Emmanuel Macron à contetemps qui
est paru aux éditions Bayard Émile
Lecler bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
directeur d'études à odoxa Rachel
garaval Carcel bonsoir et bienvenue
journaliste politique au quotidien 20
Minutes bienvenue à vous j'accueille
également duplexe Marc Lazar professeur
é mérite d'histoire et de sociologie
politique à sciencep euh auteur d'une
histoire du Parti communiste français
publié au au presse universitaire de
France bienvenue à vous Mathieu
croissandau hitorialiste politique est
resté euh à mes côtés le le Parti
socialiste on l'a vu qui suspend donc sa
participation aux travaux de la la Nupe
au sein de l'Assemblée nationale lucide
Schmid c'était inévitable ça y est on
peut dire que c'est fini la Nupe ou ça
survit encore un tout petit peu non je
crois qu'un moratoire c'est pas un
enterrement un moratoire c'est une
manière de gagner du temps et c'était
aussi une manière pour Olivier fort de
faire face à ses opposants interne vous
avez montré Patrick canner nous
expliquant que tout ça n'allait pas
assez loin et au fond ce qui est
marquant c'est que sur ce sujet de la
nup il y a eu des opposants internes il
y a le Parti communiste au sein du Parti
socialiste de longue date il y avait des
opposants et donc le problème c'est en
fait de gagner du temps au moment où
l'actualité internationale est aussi
dramatique et du coup de ne pas être en
situation de prendre des positions
politiques claires parce qu'au fond ce
sont sans doute les conflits internes
qui l'emportent et qui font gagner du
temps alors que c'est le moment ou
jamais d'avoir des position politique
clair Émile Leclerc cet éclatement de la
de la nupse dont le le sondage vous avez
réalisé pour nos confrères du du Figaro
c'est le souhait exprimé par une
majorité de Français exactement on avait
six Français sur 10 à la suite des des
différentes prises de position des
différents partis sur ce qui se passait
en en Israël on avait 6 Fran 6 Français
sur 10 qui nous disait bah oui il faut
que le Parti socialiste Parti communiste
et les écologistes quittent laanupes
parce que c'est c'est c'est pas
acceptable et c'était une 61 % de oui 37
% de exactement et c'était une idée qui
était approuvée par les tris/4 des
sympathisants socialistes alors c'éit
beaucoup plus partagé chez les
écologistes et évidemment les insoumis
étaient opposés défavoraable mais c'est
une position qui est largement partagée
donc le moratoire du Parti socialiste
correspond exactement avec l'opinion de
leurs électeurs ouais Rachel garaval
Carcel est-ce que le finalement la la
crainte des uns et des autres c'est de
d'être accusé d'être les fausoyeurs de
la Nupe est-ce que ça explique pas tout
ce qu'on est en train de vivre depuis là
de jours ou même depuis des semaines
complètement il y a il y a rien de très
clair personne ne veut avoir de parolle
complètement définitive parce que
personne ne veut porter la
responsabilité d'avoir effectivement tué
laanupesse même un Fabien Roussel par
exemple qui a pourtant été
insulé par par des proches de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui a été largement brocardé
ben même lui il ose pas vraiment le
faire parce qu'il ne peut pas vraiment
il n'a pas de majorité dans son parti on
l'a bien vu dimanche pour acter une
vraie sortie de la donc ils disent ils
on le mot impasse mais il n'acte pas une
sortie de la nuupe oui et puis aussi
parce qu'il faut dire euh malgré tout
l'idée d'union de la gauche elle reste
populaire dans l'électorat de gauche et
peut-être à part à la direction de
LFI personne ne pense réellement qu'une
victoire est possible sans union en 2027
ouais euh Marc Lazar cette marque pardon
d'employer ce terme mais c'est aussi ça
cette marque nup ou ou nupes elle
restera quoi une étoile filante elle est
maintenant trop chargée de division ou
de polémique parce qu'on se dit personne
veut euh en être étiqueté fausoyur et
peut-être que certains veulent la garder
cette marque ou pas selon vous est-ce
qu'elle est définitivement perdue ben je
crois qu'il faut effectivement attendre
mais c'est ce qui me frappe moi c'est
une grande constante de l'histoire de la
gauche dans ce pays c'est-à-dire que
lorsqu'on veut rompre des unions on le
fait au nom de l'Union ça c'est vraiment
ce qui s'est passé par exemple en 1977
au moment de la rupture du programme
commun entre le Parti socialiste et le
Parti communiste français parce que il y
a justement cette aspiration à l'unité
de ce que l'on appelle le peuple de
gauche parce que l'opposition doit être
faite à la droite et et et à l'extrême
droite aujourd'hui et par conséquent
celui qui prendrait trop la
responsabilité de faire exploser cette
unité risquerait de le payer très cher
donc c'est c'est tout le jeu d'équili je
crois de tous les protagonistes qui
savent que chacun d'entre eux veut
défendre ses intérêts les vers les
socialistes les communistes et la France
insoumise mais surtout de ne pas
effectivement apparaître comme le
responsable de la fin de cette union et
tout le problème ça va être de savoir si
on peut recomposer un certain nombre
d'éléments ou si c'est irréversible
justement comme ça avait été le cas
justement avec la rupture du programme
commun en 1977 Mathieu bah il faut que
l'Union a un sens pour qu'elle
fonctionne la nuupè c'est un accord
électoral un accord électoral remporté
pour remporter des élections les ont pas
remporté Jean-Luc Mélenchon éta allé
chercher ses alliés pour devenir Premier
ministre il espérait pouvoir l'être ça
n'a pas été le cas et les autres avaient
accepté pour pouvoir sauver leur siège
donc c'était un accord éoral mais pour
faire quand je dis pour faire l'union il
faut qu'il y ait un sens c'est quand
même deux gauches on les a dit
irréconciliiables mais qui n'ont pas du
tout la même culture il y a une gauche
dite réformiste qui s'ie avec une gauche
dite radicale ou que certains peuvent
définir comme révolutionnaire c'est des
gens qui n'ont pas la même culture il y
a des une gauche d'élus locaux qui gère
des municipalités qui gère des
départements qui gèent des régions ça
c'est plutôt le Parti communiste le
Parti socialiste quelques ver et puis
une gauche qui est une gauche plutôt
incantatoire qui dispose de mandat mais
surtout à l'Assemblée nationale voir au
Parlement européen mais qui est très peu
implanté localement et puis enfin ils
n'ont pas le même horizon stratégique ni
la même tactique le même horizon
stratégique pour la France insoumise
c'est quand même de renverser le système
c'est quand même de Renou de changer de
République de changer de paradigme
économique de changer de par paradigme
écologique c'est pas le cas des autres
des socialistes même chez certains
communistes ils veulent pas renverser la
table ils veulent amender le système
mais ils veulent pas et puis je disais
pas la même tactique c'estàdire que il y
en a pour qui il faut conquérir le
pouvoir d'une façon sociologique ça
c'est plutôt les socialistes les
communistes en s'adressant au plus grand
nombre possible donc ça fait des
programmes où on discute pour tout le
monde et puis fille est plutôt dans une
logique arithmétique je choisis des
cibles que j'additionne et qui vont me
permettre de faire le plus gros score
donc les centr-ville les écologistes en
un programme plus écolo que les écolos
les banlieux et comme ça ça me permettra
d'arriver en en tête au premier tour
voilà et donc le le problème c'est que
si on résume il y en a qui ont une
culture de second tour pour gagner il
faut remporter une majorité et il y en a
qui ont plutôt une culture de premier
tour et à mon avis ça c'est plutôt la
France alors évidemment l'élément
déclencheur c'est la réaction de de la
France insoumise à l'attaque terroriste
du Hamas contre Israël qui a précipité
on va dire cette cette rupture et je
vous propose une image comme un symbole
cette conférence de presse à l'Assemblée
en réponse aux critiques qui se sont
exprimé Mathilde Panau qui est
présidente du groupe LFI à l'Assemblée
répond elle est embarrassée vous allez
voir la question d'un journaliste la
question est simple le Hamas est-il une
organisation
terroriste c'est une la branche armée
qui aujourd'hui est responsable de
crimes de guerre voilà et don et c'est
largement documenté vous pouvez
terrorist mais j'ai répondu sur
terroriste en fait organisation
terroriste ou pas j'ai répondu sur
terroristme EUR consid et bien j'ai
répondu sur terroristme
si si vous vous contenterez de ma de de
ma réponse sur cette question double
langage non je n'ai pas de double
langage monsieur je ne vous permet
pas émil Lecler vous avez également
sondé les les Français alors ceux qui
étaient au courant des prises de
position de de LFI de cette absence on
va dire de condamnation claire ils sont
très critiques oui exactement alors on a
détaillé pour chacun des grands partis
si les français étaient au courant au
nom de de leur prise d'opposition déjà
ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que les
positions de la France insoumises
étaient les plus connu puisque c'est
celle dont on a le plus parlé évidemment
et c'est aussi les plus réprouvé très
largement 86 % des Français qui nous
disaient avoir entendu parler des prises
de position de la France insoumise était
en désaccord avec eux donc c'est c'est
colossal c'est quasiment un SC un score
stalinien tandis que pour les autres
partis pour la droite et pour le centre
même pour l'extrême droite même pour
leur assemblée nationale vous aviez 7
Français sur 10 qui avaient entendu
parler des prè d'opposition de ses
parties qui nous disaient je suis
d'accord ça c'était vraiment au
lendemain de de l'attaque contre Israël
si on posait la la question aujourd'hui
avec ce qui se passe aujourd'hui avec
l'attaque de de Gaza peut-être que les
choses évolueraient un peu mais en tout
cas la droite et le centre étaient
largement approuvé et un peu moins les
socialistes mais c'était quand même très
majoritaire et un peu moins les
écologistes sans doute parce que il y a
une partie des écologistes qui dans
l'opinion est assimilé aux insoumis dans
son côté un peu radical voilà ce qui
peut expliquer ça donc c'était vraiment
la spécificité des insoumis c'était les
seuls à être désapprouvés par les
français Luc Schmid pourquoi c'est si
difficile pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon et ses
fidèles Mathilde Panau ou encore hier
Daniel auonau de condamner clairement le
terrorisme du ramas je ne sais pas je
pense que en plus c'est une erreur même
tactique et je ne comprends pas cette
manière de santété surtout dans
l'erreur ça vient d'être dit
d'ailleurs ça ça correspond pas en plus
à à la vision électorale je voulais
rappeler par rapport à ce que disait
tout à l'heure Mathieu croissando que
certes c'était une alliance
électorale l'année dernière mais c'était
aussi une manière de ressusciter la
gauche c'est-à-dire que il faut se
rappeler que Emmanuel Macron avait été
élu sur l'idée de dépasser la droite et
la gauche et donc je pense qu'il y a
autour de cette envie de ne pas être le
faux oyur de la de la nuupesse il y a
l'idée aussi de ne pas être le faux
oyeur d'une gauche ressuscitée d'une
manière un petit peu miraculeuse il y a
un an et demi du coup l'attitude de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et de ceux qui sont
autour de lui est une attitude que je
trouve personnellement incompréhensible
parce que c'est lui qui a aidé je dire
c'est le tribin c'est le c'est le leader
de cette gauche on peut le regretter on
peut regretter ses outrances mais
aujourd'hui il y a je je vois pas
d'autres tribins à gauche à part
Jean-Luc méchant j'en vois beaucoup qui
essay mais je crois qu'il n'y arrive pas
pour l'instant et donc tout le sujet
c'est au fond comment est-ce que celui
qui a permis la résurrection devient en
fait le fauxoyeur et ça c'est un
problème et du coup ceux qui sont autour
de lui parce que on pourrait dire
F c'est pas seulement Jean-Luc Mélenchon
et notamment il a choisi de pas être élu
on pourrait dire que Mathilde
panneau d'autres qui sont plus critiques
d'ailleurs qui ont commencé à le faire
comme François Ruffin des personnalités
comme Clémentine tin ont montré qu'au
fond il y a une sorte de malaise qui
tient aussi sans doute aux paroles de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon jusqu'à quel point
est-ce qu'on peut s'éloigner de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et faire exister la France à
soumise alors loin de Jean-Luc mélchon
ça on en reparlera mais je voudrais
qu'on reste sur cette question
palestinienne de et et de ce que ça
provoque dans la perception par
l'opinion vous l'avez évoqué mais aussi
dans les critiques écoutons ensemble
ellisabeth morne la première ministre
qui qui est à l'assemé nationale et qui
dit que LFI est exclu du champ
républicain écoutonsla depuis le 7
octobre les voix de la France insoumises
manquent à la condamnation unanime de la
barbarie terroriste elle manque à
l'unité nationale vous avez tenté de
justifier vos ambiguités mais ce matin
la réalité est apparu au grand jour la
justice est saisie elle tranchera mais
en entendant prop
je pense à ces jeunes tués lors d'une
fête je pense à ces massacres dans les
kibuts de Berry et de quaraza je pense à
ces femmes ces hommes ces personnes ces
personnes âgées et ses enfants enlevés
pour vous ce ne sont pas des actes
terroristes pour moi vous vous excluez
du champ
républicain Marc Lazar LF c'est
c'est-elle exclue du champ républicain
avec cette prise de position et puis
surtout comment vous l'analysez comment
vous l'expliquez monsieur je vais
commencer par le deuxième aspect de
votre question parce que je pense que
c'était un élément très important la
cause palestinienne la gauche l'a
épousé elle a souvent hésité sur les
modes d'action des organisations
palestiniennes en 1972 au moment des
Jeux Olympiques àunique et des attentats
épouvantables contre les athlètes
israéliens ça a divisé entre ceux qui
l'ont soutenu un certain vie pleinelle
et ceux qui l'ont condamné déjà il y
avait ces hésitations mais ici le fait
nouveau effectivement c'est devant la
barbarie du Hamas d'avoir cette position
de la France insoumise pourquoi je pense
qu'il y a deux mots qu'il veulent pas
employer c'est terroriste et islamiste
les deux mots qu'ils ne veulent pas
utiliser et je pense que c'est lié à
leur conception idéologique je suis pas
tout à fait d'accord avec Luc Schmidt je
pense que c'est pas une erreur je pense
que ça c'est c'est c'est véritablement
maintenant devenu un des éléments de de
de leur corpus idéologique c'est-à-dire
que pour eux la cause palestinienne
justifie tous les moyens d'action c'est
un vieux débat dans les luttes
anticolonialistes et le débat SARC sur
la guerre d'Algérie par exemple et bien
c'est la cause palestinienne c'est la
résistance palestinienne donc bon bien
sûr il y a quelques crimes mais on va
pas employer l'expression de de
terrorisme mais islamiste c'est pas
possible pour eux de l'employer parce
que ils considèrent que c'est
l'expression de ceux qui sont dominés et
eux ils sont du côté de ceux qui sont
dominés et si on emploie islamiste ça
voudrait dire qu'on fait preuve
d'islamophobie et ça c'est inacceptable
selon eux et ce qui est gravissime et
c'est pour ça que je retiens de ce point
de vue-là un peu ce qu'a dit Mathieu
croissando même si dans le passé he les
gauches étaient irréconciliables entre
socialistes et communistes et pourtant
ils se sont mis d'accord mais là il y a
un point de non retour parce que ça
renvoie un sujet extraordinairement
sensible euh le Hamas il ne veut pas un
une perspective de deux état euh la
gauche c'est une gauche qui dit on peut
avoir un État palestinien mais il faut
reconnaître le fait national israélien
le Hamas veut tout détruire absolument
tout détruire Israël n'existe pas pour
lui au nom de la religion et par
conséquent ici c'est une position très
importante qu'a prise Jean-Luc Mélenchon
et ses proches et qui a aussi une
dimension tactique parce qu'on sait
qu'il vise un électorat composé de
français d'origine arabe et et musulmane
qui a voté en parti pour lui au derniè
présidentiel et donc ils surfent
là-dessus et évidemment le reste de la
gauche et notamment les socialistes plus
que d'ailleurs que les vers et les
communistes sont très attachés à la
laïcité donc cette conception de
soutenir un mouvement islamiste n'est
pas acceptable là c'est c'est vraiment
un sujet très important alors exclure du
front du du camp républain rapidement
oui très rapidement je je je crois que
c'est une posture politique très
franchement parce qu'on aurait pu dire
la même chose du Parti communiste dans
les années 50 d'ailleurs ça a été un
débat au moment de la guerre froide
est-ce qu'il fallait interdire le Parti
communiste français ou pas qui était
totalement aligné sur l'Union soviétique
qui disait par exemple on ne fera jamais
la guerre à l'Union soviétique si jamais
il y avait une guerre et on ne l'a pas
fait et je pense que la République la 4e
République si qui a toujours été mal
aimé je crois qu'elle a bien faitce
qu'elle représenter quelque chose dans
le pays qu'en plus au sein de la France
insoumise justement il y a des débats
importants donc je pense que c'est
essentiellement une posture politique de
la part de la première ministre de la
première ministre merci Marc Lazar je
reviens vers vous tout à l'heure Rachel
garaval Carcel c'est c'est quand même ce
terme de champ républicain exclus du
champ républicain c'était réservé au
font national c'est quand même frappant
de voir que aujourd'hui le le
gouvernement le réserve à LFI oui ben on
assiste depuis plusieurs mois à une
sorte de retournement de de la
diabolisation d'une certaine manière et
le gouvernement bien aidé par fi euh il
souscrit complètement je je pense qu'il
a T parce que enfin là on est quand même
à deux doigts de dire que la France
insoumise soutient le Hamas ce n'est pas
le cas ils ont 1000 fois tort de pas les
qualifier de groupes terroristes et de
pas qualifier les actes de de d'attaqu
terroristes mais la France insoumise ne
soutient pas le Hamas encore moins parce
que ce uné de défendre la cause paltin
absolument d'accord c'est terroriste je
suis 1000 fois d'accord avec vous pour
moi ils ont une position de gauchiste au
sens léiniste vous savez c'est la
maladie infantile du communisme ou du
socialisme j'ai un doute c'està-dire en
fait ils ont une position un peu qu'on
qu'on pourrait éventuellement défendre
dans un dans un café philo d'extrême
gauche oui le terrorisme c'est pas si
simple que ça mais là c'est autre chose
qu'on attend du parti leader de la
gauche mais on peut pas dire que la
France insoumise est un parti qui
soutient le Hamas à gauche certains je
pense en grand Bretagne j Corbin par
exemple disait que le hzbollah ou le
Hamas était des amis pas souvenir qu'il
y a des gens de la France insoumise qui
a dit ça derni non mais il y a des gens
il y a des gens comme Daniel auono qui
ont invité Jérémy Corbin pendant la
campagne des législativ oui non mon oui
moi je crois qu'il y a une chose
importante c'est que je contrairement à
ce que pense Marc Lazar moi en tout cas
je pense que c'est une erreur très
fondamentale même en terme de
communication politique et un entêement
de gan-luc Mélenchon qui traduit aussi
son rôle de leader maximo après autour
de lui il y a un certain nombre de
personnes qui reprennent sa pensée et
qui la répète comme des perroquets et je
pense que ça rejoint le malaise qu'on
sent chez mathil Panau qui répète comme
un perroquet après je rappellerai quand
même que François Ruffin qui nous avait
dit d'ailleurs qu'il voulait réconcilier
la France des Bours et la France des
tours ce qui pose la question pour le
coup de l'électorat musulman par rapport
à un électorat plus rural et cetera
voilà il y a il y a aussi des voix
discordantes qui se sont fait entendre
du côté de LFI et donc on nous dit le le
PS donc fait son moratoire après la
question de la France insoumise c'est
est-ce que certains au sein de la France
insoumise veulent que la nupes continue
bien que Jean-Luc Mélenchon d'une
certaine manière comme je le disais s'en
facee le faossoyeur il y a le côté où
personne ne veut accepter d'enterrer
l'anupesse mais il y a la question de
comment est-ce qu'on continue laanupess
que certains devraient assumer en terme
de de questionnement et en terme
d'initiative et pas seulement ce
différencion à minima de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon il y a un moment où il faut
tuer le père hein voilà allez l'avenir
de la nuupes l'avenir de l'Union de la
gauche on y reviendra plus tard mais je
voudrais qu'on jette un un coup d'œil
dans dans le rétroviseur parce que
finalement ce qui est en train de se se
passer bon il y a eu des signes
annonciateurs c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire Marion Vigreux peut nous
rejoindre tout de suite on va on va
retracer avec vous Marion quelques-uns
des moments fort qui ont participé acté
cette division de l'anupe oui puisque
lorsqu'elle voit le jour le 7 mai 2022
l'anupes veut regrouper les principales
forces de gauche pour présenter des
candidatures communes mais très vite on
se rend compte qu'il n'est pas si facile
de faire cohabiter des idées des projets
politiques différents les premières
frictions elles interviennent 3 mois
après sa création en août 2022 sur une
question internationale et quand
Jean-Luc Mélenchon déclare sur son blog
que Taïwan est une composante à part
entière de la Chine un argument qui est
défendu par les autorités chinoises et
que critiqueront vivement les
socialistes et les écologistes autre
fracture cette fois-ci stratégique en
février 2023 avec l'examen de la réforme
des retraites lorsque le texte arrive à
l'Assemblée nationale 20000 amendements
ont été déposés parmi eux 13000 viennent
des insoumis et ces derniers refuseront
d'en supprimer contrairement aux autres
formations de gauche conséquence les
débats prennent fin le 17 février sans
que l'examen de l'article 7 sur le
report de l'âge de départ à la retraite
n'ait pu avoir lieu et ça ne plaît pas à
certains syndicats comme aux alliés de
gauche et je vous propose d'écouter la
réaction à l'époque d'Olivier fort le
premier secrétaire du Parti socialiste
c'est vrai qu'il y a un différent
stratégique tactique plutôt sur la
conduite des opérations parce que nous
voulions aller à l'article 7 et mettre
face à leur responsabilité l'ensemble
des élus de CE par Parlement alors après
ces débats ils seront nombreux à appeler
un acte 2 de laanupè à noter que
l'examen de la réforme de la retraite a
également été marqué par des dérapages
verbaux qui vont crisper certains élus
par exemple le député et les fi Orens
saintthoule qui traite le ministre du
Travail d'assassin ou encore ce montage
photo réalisé par Thomas porte député
LFI qui écrase un ballon à l'effigie
d'Olivier du sopte le député avait reçu
le soutien de LFI mais pas du reste des
alliés de gauche qui avaient alors
dénoncé une violence symbolique et
soutenu des sanctions autre divergence
quelques semaines plus tard autour de la
question de la réintégration d'Adrien
catenin sur les ban de l'Assemblée nous
sommes en avril 2023 et ce retour ne
fait pas l'unanimité là aussi le député
etfi du Nord a été condamné pour des
violences conjugales et revient après 4
mois d'absence le Parti socialiste
publie un communiqué pour condamner je
cite une réintégration inacceptable une
faute politique un sentiment qui est
aussi partagé dans le rond des
écologistes maintenant on est à l'été
2023 l'invité ation du rappeur mdine aux
universités d'été de les f et d'Europe
Écologie les vers et les vers sont
divisés hein sur sa présence puisque
mdine est accusé de propos antisémite
sur le réseau social X il s'en est
excusé évoquant des propos inadaptés
mais Jean-Luc Mélenchon l' défendu
dénonçant au passage la soumission de
certains écologistes on est à peine
sorti de cette polémique Médine que une
nouvelle crise s'invite et cette fois-ci
c'est autour de l'interdiction de laaba
à l'école décision prise par le
gouvernement pour cette rentrée scolaire
2023 fille dénonce une police du
vêtement mais chez les socialistes et
les communistes cette interdiction est
accueillie plutôt favorablement le
député PS jérô Gedge évoque lui une
nécessaire police du prosélitisme à
l'école autant d'exemples qui de de de
fractures qui se sont qui ont donc
apparu au fur et à mesure des mois
jusqu'à la polémique de trop vous l'avez
évoqué celle de la position considéré
comme ambigu de LFI sur l'attaque du
Hamas contre Israël merci beaucoup
Marion Émile Lecler est-ce que au fil de
ces euh polémiques euh le le le soutien
euh populaire de des électeurs de gauche
à laanup s'est effrité au même rythme
vous voyez ce que je veux dire il y a en
tout cas une une image qui s'est
dégradée on avait mené une enquête au
lendemain hein de de des élections
législative en juin 2022 euh pour Public
Sénat notamment euh dans laquelle on
mesurait l'image l'opinion qu' avaient
les Français euh de l'anupes elle était
de 36 % en juin 2023 donc un an après
elle é elle était tombée à 31 %. et il y
a une image en fait qui est très radical
dans l'opinion en fait l'opinion
n'associe pas la nuups à l'ensemble des
parties qui la compose mais
essentiellement à la France insoumise
donc les traits d'images qui sont
associés à la nupes sont aussi ceux
qu'on associe à à la France insoumise
donc c'est la stratégie de de du conflit
permanent en quelque sorte qui est
retenu par major les exemples qu'on a
donné sont des exemples dont on a
beaucoup parlé qui ont fait polémique
mais il y a aussi des sujet de fond au
départ au moment même de la création de
l'anupes qui posait problème au sein
même de la gauche he des thématiques
comme comme l'Europe le communautarisme
et cetera étai des vrais sujets de
divergence profonde au-delà de la
tactique politique et des manières de de
procéder donc il y a une image de l' NPS
qui est associée à la France insoumise
et qui pose un un vrai problème et une
association aussi qui est très forte
avec Jean-Luc méenchon qui est le seul
et et unique grand leader qui a vraiment
le leadership de de de toutes ces
composantes un mot de du Conseil
national du psier pour justifier le
moratoire Olivier fort a dit qu' N pas
signé pour la
bordélisation sauf que enfin c'est
pardon mais la bordélisation je reprends
le terme ce sont ceux d'Olivier fort
c'est stratégie du confit permanent elle
est là depuis le début il la découvre
pas aujourd'hui je veux dire non mais
c'est ça mais c'est c'est moi ça m'a
fait tomber de la cha de lire ça
d'ailleurs comment dire la la la forme
qu'a pris cette dernière polémique fond
ressemble totalement à toutes les autres
en fait c'est-à-dire il y a une
initiative de LFI qui déplaitt aux
autres LFI ne veut jamais s'excuser
reculer ou quoi que ce soit du coup les
autres sont bien embêtés euh en fait
c'est une grande arlaisienne depuis le
début de de l'anub c'est-à-dire euh
tenter d'avoir entre eux les partenaires
de l'Alliance un lieu de de régulation
des prises de parole d'une certaine
manière et c'est un peu ce que demande
par exle Boris Vallot le oui le
président du groupe socialiste à
l'Assemblée ciel Chatelin il y a
quelques mois quand elle demandait un
acte 2 de l'anupe mais la vérité c'est
que je suis pas sûr que ces conditions
de de régulation des prises de parole
les socialistes les écologistes et les
communistes puissent se les appliquer à
eux-même c'est pour ça quand certes
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il a une grande
responsabilité dans ce qui se passe
mais il faut aussi souligner
l'hypocrisie des partenaires làd alors
vous parliez de Jean-Luc Mélenchon a
parlé de son son avenir et d'éventuel
successeur mais mais d'abord on écoute
la députée socialiste du pu d'Ô
Christine
pierrezbone si Mélenchon aime la gauche
ben il doit il doit s'effacer voilà très
clairement si c'est ça le l'intérêt
général de d'arriver à construire une
alternative aujourd'hui il doit
s'effacer et il doit laisser ceux qui
sont en responsabilité il n'est plus il
n'est plus député aujourd'hui il fallait
qu'il se présente il est plus député qui
nous laisse construire une alternative
d'ailleurs c'était le titre d'un livre
signé qui signé Jean-Luc Mélenchon
faites mieux vers une révolution
citoyenne on va revoir la couverture de
de ce livre et puis c'est même aussi ce
qu'il avait dit au soir du du premier
tour de la dernière élection
présidentielle voilà grosso modo j'ai
fait mon mon job à vous de de faire
mieux Matthieu est-ce que cette
implosion de la nuub c'est l'échec de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon mais c'est un échec
en trompleuil car en vérité c'est
exactement ce que souhaitait Jean-Luc
Mélenchon l dans d'un soumis qui aime
qu'on lui obéisse le doigt sur la
couture du pantalon on avait RAL bol de
ses alliés rékel Citran pour lesquels il
n'a que le plus grand mépris hein il se
voit comme celui qui a réveillé la
gauche il se voit comme celui qui a fait
les 22 % alors se faire faire la leçon
euh par des socialistes ou des
communistes qu'il considèrent comme des
vestiges d'une classe politique qui a
soit failli soit trahi c'est la goutte
de trop mais surtout Jean-Luc Mélenchon
avait alerté dès le printemps dernier
vous vous en souvenez même d je crois
que c'était c'était d'ailleurs dans 20
minutes ilil a donné une interview pour
dire l'anupes est en péril si elle n'est
même plus un accord électoral parce que
je le rappelais l'anupes c'est un accord
électoral et depuis il n'y en a plus eu
et ça a marché pour législativ mais il y
en a pas eu pour les sénatoriales il y
en aura pas pour les europé puisque
chacun part en solo et puis il y en aura
vraisemblablement pas même s'il est trop
tôt pour les présidentiels puisque quand
même le mois dernier Jean-Luc Mélanchon
a dit LF finira jamais dans une primaire
de la gauche comment ils vont décider on
verra bien mais le seul problème donc
jeanich Jean-Luc méanchon l'avait prédit
donc aujourd'hui on y est d'une certaine
façon le péril dans la nuupse mais c'est
que le problème pour je menchan c'est
que ça ne s'est pas tout à fait passé
comme comme prévu c'està-dire qu'est-ce
qu'on peut dire de plus mais depuis des
semaines en fait on l'a dit un peu sur
ce plateau les membres de la nup jou à
qui craquera le premier personne ne
voulant endosser la responsabilité
d'avoir cassé l'alliance malheur à celui
qui fait péter la nuèe vous souvenez
c'est ce que prophétisait Jérôme Gedge
le député socialiste qui aujourd'hui dit
pi que pendre de l'alliance avec LFI du
coup de son côté Jean-Luc Mélenchon
faisait comme d'habitude il cultivait
ses provocations en espérant secrètement
que ses alliés finiraient par claquer la
porte oui mais voilà en s'enfonçant
piteusement et de façon assez indigne à
mes yeux au lendemain des attaques sur
le Hamas ben les insoumis sont allés
trop loin ils se sont enferrés dans leur
circonvolution et ce sont eux du coup
qui ont cassé le fil en donnant le
sentiment de Rener toute à la fois leurs
valeurs et leurs principes humanistes
l'histoire retiendra que ce sont les
excès des insoumis et de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et de ses amis qui ont cassé
la nupes et non pas la couardise
d'Olivier fort comme on entendait ou la
traitrice de Fabien Roussel comme
escomtait les insoumis bon si on parle
d'avenir jeanque Mélenchon va pas
arrêter la politique non bien sûr que
non et vous allez voir comme à chaque
fois Jean-Luc Mélenchon finira par
changer de rôle à l'approche de la
présidentielle parce que dans les
premières années de quinena il est
toujours dans le rôle du méchant pour
cliver pour affaiblir pour
conflictualiser comme il dit et puis 2
ans av avant les élections ben il se
fait soudain plus patelin plus gentil il
oublie le bruit et la fureur pour
incarner la figure du papier
révolutionnaire mais rassembleur
Jean-Luc Mélenchon est persuadé qu'il
sera meilleur que tout le monde à gauche
en campagne électorale de toute façon et
pour le coup l'histoire récente plutôt
donner Resson il ne pense pas que c'est
l'union qui fait la force mais que c'est
la force qui fait l'union donc s'il est
fort les gens se regrouperont autour de
lui c'est une tactique qui lui a permis
d'enregistrer de bons scores au premier
tour mais tout en échouant à chaque fois
aux portes du second débat pour lui
c'est faites mieux ou faites pire Luc
Schmith qui qui pourrait incarner la la
suite maisême si on a bien compris que
il va pas passer la main comme ça
Jean-Luc Mélenchon je pense qu'il y a un
sujet sur les personnalités et les
partis politiques ça a été rappelé par
Mathieu croissandoo dans une grande
démocratie en général on a un parti
socialiste plutôt fort et là ce qui est
effrayant pour le Parti socialiste c'est
qu'il a fait des scorses extrêmement
faibles à la dernière présidentielle et
qu'il a été victime d'une loi léonine et
mathématique dans le cadre des de
l'accord de l'anupes donc le sujet c'est
est-ce que par exemple les socialistes
pourraient retrouver au fond cette forme
de gauche réformiste et gestionnaire aux
responsabilités et puis il y a cette
question écologiste qui est très
importante c'està-dire que tout le monde
aujourd'hui se di vert et évidemment il
y a cette force montante qui par
ailleurs on le voit reste quand même
très adolescente par rapport à ce qui
s'est dit sur mdine par exemple sur
lequel en plus ils ont cette incapacité
à assumer alors que LFI assument c'estàd
quex ils invitent mdine honteusement ils
se divisent LF fi invitent Médine et
assume donc il y a un vrai sujet sur la
façon dont cette grande cause verte
pourrait donner lieu à un parti
politique à la hauteur donc moi je ne
vois pas de de leader immédiat en
revanche je trouve que construire du
collectif permettrait sans doute de
faire émerger des leaders auxquels on ne
pense pas aujourd'hui et je crois que
c'est l'inverse évidemment de la méthode
mélanchonienne je voulais aussi rappeler
une chose puisqu'on a beaucoup parlé de
des anicroches qui avit eu auparavant
c'était un petit peu la cour de récré là
c'est pas du tout le cas le sujet c'est
la vie la mort le terrorisme et par
rapport à ce qu'a dit Marc Lazar sur la
cause palestinienne ce qui est effrayant
si vous voulez c'est que du coup
personne à gauche n'arrive à parler
correctement de la ca cause
palestinienne et que on se chamaille sur
est-ce que le Hamas est terroriste ou
pas et du coup par rapport à ce qui
s'est passé à l'hôpital par rapport au
morts palestiniens personne n'est
capable d'avoir une parole politique à
gauche qui soit correcte et ça c'est un
problème c'estàdire que la Nupe ne
pourra pas continuer à exister si elle
n'a pas un jour ou l'autre une espèce de
par qui s'inscrit dans la mémoire de la
gauche comme l'a rappelé Marc Lazar Marc
Lazar justement vous l'aviez écrit mai
2022 donc on est quelques semaines avant
les Législatives je crois que le titre
de votre tribun du monde c'était l'Union
est un combat je dis ça de de mémoire et
vous pointiez déjà les fragilités de de
de cette nouvelle union de la gauche
elle passe par quoi je reprends ma
question sur l'incarnation c'est d'abord
construire un programme ou c'est d'abord
trouver le chef ou la chef mais je crois
que ce serait les deux l'Union est un
combat c'est pas une formule de moi
c'était une formule du dirigeant
communiste Étienne fagon juste après
avoir signé le programme commun devant
le Comité central du Parti communiste
français où il disait que ils allaient
faire ils avaient fait une union mais
que l'Union était un combat et que cette
union c'était pour garder la prééminence
du Parti communiste comme on sait c'est
le parti socialiste qui l'a emporté bah
c'est le problème c'est à la fois
essayer de construire un programme
commun si c'est possible et Mathieu
croissando a rappelé toutes les
difficultés parce qu'il y a des
divergences importantes mais je rappelle
que dans le passé il y avait des
divergences importantes il y a toujours
une composante réformiste et une
composante plus radicale ou ou ou plus
révolutionnaire et je crois que pour
nuancer peut-être en revanche ce qu'a
dit Mathieu croissandau tout à l'heure
je crois qu'il a deux encore deux atouts
dans la main Jean-Luc
Mélanchon le premier c'est le fait que
immédiatement il a dit ah bah c'est pas
moi qui suis responsable de la division
c'est Olivier fort c'est-à-dire que du
coup il se présente comme l'élément
garant de l'unité devant entre
guillemets le le peuple de gauche le
deuxième élément qu'il a en sa faveur
c'est que mais notre ami sondur va
pouvoir peut-être êre m'firmer ou me
confirmer c'est qu'il y a un noyau dur
là je vous parle depuis Rome on appelle
il y a une belle expression zocolod duro
donc il il y a un noyau dur si vous
voulez qui qui est là et je constate que
dans les enquêtes d'opinion pour les
élections européennes qui ont été faites
ces jours-ci la base électorale de la
France insoumise qui est basse he pour
le moment pour les élections européennes
n'a pas bougé c'est 9 % donc apparemment
ce noyau dur il résiste et puis le
troisème élément on vient de le dire
avec Lucile c'est Lucile Schmith c'est
que son grand tout mais c'est qu'il y a
pas d'incarnation de l'autre côté le
pôle réformiste pour le moment c'estàd
celui du Parti socialiste des vers et du
PCF n'a pas un leader et en plus c trois
partis qui sont en compétition entre eux
donc c'est extraordinairement difficile
alors Émile Leclerc évidemment je repose
la question de Marc Lazard le noyau dur
il est toujours là effectiv confirme
effectivement il y a toujours un noyau
dur maintenant c'est à la fois une force
parce que ça permet d'avoir un socle
électoral systématique d'une certaine
manière et c'est aussi une faiblesse
parce que jeanl Mélenchon est
extrêmement clivant dans l'opinion vous
avez toujours à peu près alors là il
baisse encore ces dernières semaines
dans l'opinion mais il est extrêmement
clivant c'est une des personnalités les
plus rejetées par les Français euh donc
il y a une popularité et en même temps
il y a personne qui se dit bon bah oui
j'ai pas d'opinion particulière sur
cette personnalité je repousse ces idées
de manière catégorique voilà ce que se
disent la la grande majorité des
française disa Marc Lazard par vous
interrompre il y il y a le le fait que
effectivement juste après le moratoire
le résultat du moratoire jeanque menchon
a a tweté la responsabilité deolivier
for sauf que est-ce que dans l'opinion
c'est perçu comme ça c'est qui est perçu
comme responsable de la la fin ou la
quasi fin de Laan nuupe à ma
connaissance la question n'a pas été
posée mais probablement que la France
insoumise sortirait en tête de de cette
question c'est assez assez probable et
pour revenir sur ce que je disais
précédemment la la personnalité de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon pose un problème au
sein de laanupes et effectivement comme
vous le comme on l'a tous dit sur ce
plateau il y a personne qui suit
derrière qui peut Ré ement émergé et en
particulier dans les autres parties que
sont le parti socialiste ou europcologie
les ver donc c'est la gros difficulté
valgarel vous avez signé un papier pour
20 minutes sur Françis Ruffin est-ce
qu'il fait partie de ceux qui en tout
cas il travaill pour quoi pour incarner
une voilà une une alternative on peut
dire ça comme ça dans un monde
politicomédiatique où c'est terriblement
difficile
d'émerger il y a quelqu'un qui existe et
c'est pas anodin et puis on a et je me
mets d' dedans on a toujours un peu de
mal à à voir un peu plus loin que le
bout de son nez mais euh Jean-Luc
Mélenchon n'a pas toujours été le leader
présidentiable évident qu'il est
aujourd'hui avant l'élection
présidentielle de 2017 c'était pas du
tout ça c'est 2017 qui lui donne une
nouvelle stature l'histoire de la gauche
et de la vie politique française c'est
des leader qu'on a pas vu venir qui
s'impose de manière inattendue je parle
même pas de Macron j'ose pas en 95
personnes le voit venir pour être
candidat du Parti socialiste et il y en
a d'autres des exemples comme ça donc on
est on est à 3 ans disons dans 3 ans on
y verra surans doute un peu plus clair 3
ans c'est c'est tellement long mais mais
pour rester sur parce que on on va pas
faire tous les papabilés hein mais pour
rester sur sur François rifffin il
travaille vraiment ça veut dire quoi il
travaille le terrain il pose des jalons
il est vraiment dans cette perspective
présidentielle ce que les gens qui sont
proches de lui ou qui ont un regard
plutôt favorable sur son sur ce qu'il
fait il nous explique que c'est un
bosseur qui bosse vraiment les sujets je
prends par exemple son interview au
Monde de la semaine dernière c'est la
toute première fois que François Ruffin
ose s'exprimer sur un sujet
international jusque-là euh il était
toujours en train de de beautter en
touche quand on sortait de ses sujets
habituels c'est-à-dire économiques et
sociaux donc ça montre qu'il essaie
d'élargir
d'épair sa personnalité politique et son
interview a quand même été assez
largement salué ça veut dire qu' qu'
bosse quand même des sujets qui sont pas
les siens habituellement bon allez on va
terminer là-dessus merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat ici en plateau et
et ENCI duplexe de de Rome j'ai rappelé
d'ailleurs les les titres de vos Liv
Lucile Schmith le Emmanuel Macron a
contetemps coécrit avec Olivier montgin
et publié aux éditions Bayard Marc Lazar
votre histoire du Parti communiste
français est publié au PUF et on vous
lit dans le quotidien 20 Minutes
évidemment à demain 18h 22h sur Public
Sénat notez également que l'invité de la
matinale sera le général Dominique
trinquan ancien chef de la mission
militaire française auprès des Nations
Unies bonne soirée à toutes et à
tous
[Musique]